(shoveling dirt)
- I become interested in
wanting to dig a grave
because it's such an important part of
kind of being human and
how we care for the dead,
and what we do for our loved ones,
for other people in the community.
But the way that modern funeral practices
happen in the United States,
a lot of times we're so divorced from
participating actively in this process.
It's just something that I wanted to have
learn physical experience with.
I'm Chris Naka.
I'm the Director of
video at Atlas Obscura,
and I'm gonna to try to dig a grave.
I'm a little nervous
about digging this grave
just because of the
amount of labor involved.
I don't really know what to expect.
I know the further down I go,
the harder it's going to be,
so I'm worried I'm gonna run out of gas.
It's like a reckoning
of my lifestyle choices
where I think I should've been working out
and exercising more to prepare
myself to dig this grave,
but I will pay for those
choices in the coming days.
- The Steelmantown Cemetery
is a family cemetery of mine.
My family came here in 1680
and created a bunch of little villages
that surrounded the industry of the time.
It's pretty ancient by American standards.
We are adjacent to the
Bell Plains State Forest,
which is 25,000 acres.
The Steelmantown Natural Burial Grounds,
it really revolves around the
use of non-toxic chemicals,
to not embalm bodies,
biodegradable burial containers
like shrouds or pine boxes,
no concrete vaults.
Anything that doesn't really require
a lot of natural resources
or things like that
to really steward to the next generation
and to take care of
the environment itself.
- And any pointers for a first-timer,
as far as like,
my operative assumption was to
start slow
so I don't run out of gas soon.
If I can continuously dig that
would be better than like--
- Yeah, slow and steady.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, slow and Steady.
And don't think about it too much.
Because if you start thinking about it,
like, oh, my gosh, I'm only a foot deep,
(both laugh)
you're gonna get into trouble,
so just slow and steady.
The way I try to look at it
is usually you can get about
six inches deep for every shovel full.
Every row you're six inches
closer to being done.
So all you got to do is
grab a hold of this here and
you and I can start walking her down.
[Ed] Well, essentially
the hand dig a grave,
it doesn't have to be perfect.
Essentially, a grave
typically is 32 inches wide
by about seven foot long.
It can be anywhere from
three to six foot deep
depending on the facility
or the person digging it
and if they're in a shroud
or if they're in a casket.
Really you just have to have a lot of
inner strength to get it done.
After you mark your corners,
you would then take a straight shovel,
and you would outline it
and basically start to dig.
(shovel breaking up dirt)
- Okay, now toss all this?
- Yep, and there you go.
So you got your outline.
(laughs)
Okay, you did a good job. It looks great.
- It's tough. I'm not going to lie
but the ground is really
soft here, which is great
and I'm just trying to pace myself
so I keep moving and
I don't get tired out.
There's a lot of muscles
in my body that I don't use
on a regular basis
so it's gonna feel great tomorrow
but, like Ed said, don't
think about it too much,
just go at a slow and steady pace
and every pass is six inches.
So we'll get there.
Does anyone come out here
and they request to dig
the grave themselves
for the family member?
- I've had people request
but we don't allow it
only because its so arduous,
- [Chris] Yeah.
but we allow them to participate
in all the other aspects.
It goes in a lot easier that it comes out.
- [Chris] Okay.
- So, when they want to fill it in,
it's much easier for
the family to do that.
- Well, I'm real appreciative
of you giving me a chance
to see how far I go.
- [Ed] Oh, absolutely.
I have no doubt you'll make it.
- I have doubts, Ed.
(laughs)
(grunting)
- [Chris] Like Ed said the
soil is super sandy here,
which makes it easy, but
it looks like a grave.
I mean, I feel like I'm digging a grave
as hard as that is to do
and however much I have to
go, I can definitely tell why
people who commit murder or
need to dispose of bodies
in a clandestine fashion
only go about this far because
it's hard.
- [Ed] Well, a lot of people
would've given up by now.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- That's what I mean.
It really has to do with endurance.
It's all about slow,
steady, and endurance.
- I mean it's one of the best
pieces of advice that Ed, Sr.
has been giving me is do half
shovels and just go quickly
(Ed laughs)
instead of trying to do big shovels
and yeah you'll tire yourself out.
- True, true.
- [Chris] Now I think
I'm getting down into
a little bit more rocky territory.
- [Ed] Yeah, getting into the gravel
but that also means you're
getting close to being done.
It's the right way to
think about it. (laughs)
You know it's a good lesson
for anyone to learn though
to come out and do something like this.
- Yeah.
(raking mud)
- [Chris] We hit water.
It's time to come out of the hole.
Ed says four feet is acceptable. (laughs)
But it feels good because I actually
can't believe I dug this hole.
I didn't think I would do
this well and it's crazy
that
30,000 years ago
people were doing this
to take care of the
dead and it's beautiful.
I think.
I mean it's so much work
and I have a giant appreciation
for that now. (laughs)
It's weird to feel like
an activity like digging
a grave can make you feel closer to people
but I definitely feel like it was great
spending time with Ed and Ed today.
I mean, it would've been a very lonely
enterprise to do this
by yourself. (laughs)
- [Ed] I will tell you this,
I would hire you.
You did a good job.
(Chris laughs)
- Okay, so when people would walk up
you'd hand them a shovel
and they'd get busy.
So whoever would like to join us
in this joyous event. (laughs)
Well, I got to let Chris
take the first shovel.
He's gotta throw the first shovel in.
(shoveling dirt)
Alright, here we go.